so there's a rule I have in how to
discover individuals that are worth
studying or interesting within sufism
the very critical and strict 14th
century scholar eben tamiya often what
works in which he very strongly attacked
and criticized certain Sufis as being
unbelievers or heretics because they
held in his opinion very radical views
and so the rule is that anyone that he
mentions by name in those writings those
are the interesting ones and people that
he mentions include Hinata be soldered
in Cana we have nine farad I'll sure
study and perhaps the most controversial
of them all the one that Ben Tamiya and
many others see as the most radical and
most dangerous even Sabine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
his full name was Muhammad ibn Abdul Haq
Leben Sabah Ian and even sabayon
literally means son of 70 which is
obviously rather unusual name
he has come down to us as a very
controversial figure one that is famous
for holding and spreading radical views
that interpreted the Islamic doctrine of
oneness in a very monastic way the
doctrine which he liked to call haddad
Almaty laka or absolute unity he was
born in 1216 or 1217 in al-andalus and
specifically in the Rococo Valley which
is part of the larger region of murcia
we also grew up and spent his formative
years
this of course directly places him close
to probably the most famous Andalusia
and Sufi even adavi who was also from
Murcia and only a generation or two
older than even Saleem because of their
close proximity both regionally but also
in terms of similar lives and even
teachings the great sheikh al akbar a
banana B often overshadows even
suffering completely and this is a shame
because even Sabah in is a very unique
and fascinating figure that in my
opinion deserves a lot more attention we
talked about Ana Lucia a lot in my
previous videos the 12th to 13th
centuries was an especially vibrant time
in which some of the most famous figures
in history appeared here and also
elsewhere as well Sufism or mysticism
was also flourishing in this region and
often was mixed with more speculative
philosophy or speculative thought in
general which tried to create a kind of
synthesis between the two like for
example in the famous novel high opinion
Sun by the philosopher eben to failed
one could generalize a bit and say that
the Sufis of the Western tradition in
Spain and Western North Africa was more
speculative in nature and implemented
more philosophical
terms and ideas whereas its eastern
counterpart in places like Persia was
more focused on psychological
development and poetic expressions
rather than speculative prose these
speculative and esoteric tendencies of
their mysticism in this region seems to
have been greatly influenced by the
Greek tradition and indeed very much by
Hermeticism later chroniclers talk about
these Sufis of al-andalus and mentions
that Hermeticism is especially strong
among them writers like Yvonne fatigue
and indeed even Halden mentions a group
of people from the so called wadi recoat
that is the recoat Valley who held
radical views of absolute unity or
Metallica and were also apparently very
strongly influenced by Hermeticism these
accounts were written by people who were
often very critical of this group or the
ideas that they held so which should be
taken with a grain of salt but it is
very interesting that they and many
others seem to mention this people of
the wadi record as a unique category it
seems then that they recoat valley at
this time was a place of great activity
and an intellectual environment were a
certain group of Sufis resided and held
what seems to be radical views of with
certain monastic tendencies now I would
argue that probably the views held by
the people in the world record were a
locus of larger tendencies in the region
of Spain generally but as I said much
more research needs to be done on this
subject as we've seen if in Sabah in was
born and raised in the record and thus
it is highly likely that it is this
intellectual environment and the Masters
from this region that he frequented that
was the highest or largest influence to
his own very unique ideas about absolute
unity it seems that these were ideas
that were flourishing in Andalusia at
the time and might have had a special
prominence in the record valley it is
there from my opinion that the
similarity between empanada B's unity of
being and even sovereigns absolute unity
should not be seen as a result of direct
influence as some have assumed but
instead as a result of sharing a common
intellectual environment in medieval
Spain in which these ideas were held at
the time
I mean sabayon spiritual masters in
a man called eben Allah and Ishaaq I
banal murder and eben Dahak all being
supposed people of the rowdy recruit
other than this even Saba in seems to
receive their wide and proper education
in both science and philosophy and came
to master both of these fields indeed he
became famous in his life for his
incredible intellectual knowledge and
rhetorical skills and even those of his
enemies who were very highly critical of
him even they had to humbly admit to
this fact he also received an education
the religious sciences like the Quran
and hadith and jurisprudence he was from
a well-off family but later in his life
chose a more ascetic life as a Sufi
which is often a common theme in these
kinds of biographies it seems that in
his 20s he had already cultivated a
mystical and philosophical status to the
point that he had a devoted group of
followers by the time he was around
thirty years old he left his home region
with his group of followers called the
sabi Nia to Granada from early on it
seems like even sovereigns thought was
characterized by leaning towards both
Sufism or mysticism and philosophy and
often were they kind of synthesis of the
two he held very highly some of the
Philosopher's and was particularly fond
of Hermes as we will see soon but was
nonetheless a Sufi through and through
at the same time concerned with
spiritual practices and the cultivation
of intimacy with God through intuitive
experience side Hossein Nasr writes
quote even sovereign embodies that
synthesis between the practical
spiritual life and intellectual doctrine
that one finds in in Masada he would
exclaim his controversial doctrines on
God in the world
early on the main thrust of which is
that God is the sole reality of existing
things that reality is absolute oneness
and that the world of multiplicity is an
illusion this didn't go down too well
with the local Sultan's or the
conservative jurists and he was very
much of tact for these ideas for most of
his life it may have been for this
reason that he chose to relocate outside
of his home region of Andalusia to the
city of Ceuta where he lived for a few
years undisturbed it is here while in
suta that he writes some of the most
famous and important of his literary
works for example it is here that he
composes his by far most famous work
which is called the Sicilian questions
the Sicilian questions is a work that
was written as answers in response to a
certain philosophical or theological
questions asked by the Christian emperor
frederick ii it's a very fascinating
document this is the only work by evan
sabayon that has been completely
translated into english and is also the
main reason that he is even known are
famous today but he also wrote his
probably most important mystical
philosophical work while staying in the
city which is known as buddha ADIF and
in which he explains his ideas in full
force it is said that this book angered
the authorities so much then he was
forced to flee again but most likely it
was due to other political reasons and
changes in leadership and so on
he wouldn't continue to relocate
continuously to different cities but
always having to flee or relocate
eventually maybe because of his
controversial views he lived for a while
in Algeria where he met and became a
master of the Sufi poet and his most
famous student I will hasanul sure study
sure study was actually older than even
Saleem and was at the time a follower of
the tariqa of abu modeun but when he met
even sabayon he is famously said to have
said to her study what if it is paradise
you desire then go with sheikh abu ahmad
jaan if it is the master of paradise
your desire then let's begin
after this I'll sure study became his
student and was devoted to him for the
rest of his life
as would I if someone ever said that to
me obviously they've been sabayon then
lived in Cairo Egypt for a while where
he gathered more followers but it wasn't
until he reached the city of Mecca
sometime around the Year 1250 for that
he finally found his permanent home here
he became very close with the governor
of Mecca himself Sharif a banana even a
b-side even Sabah in may even had become
a spiritual master which would of course
be very significant he spent his last 20
years under the patronage of the Sharif
of Mecca until his mysterious death in
the year twelve seventy at the young age
54 now there is controversy surrounding
his death as the common narrative is
that he committed suicide by slitting
his wrists but in my opinion and
according to many other scholars this is
most likely not true as the only sources
we have for this is written by people
who were openly hostile to him and thus
is obviously trying to paint him in
every negative light as committing a
very grave sin some instead claim that
he may have been poisoned which could of
course be true since he did still have a
number of enemies around the Muslim
world or he may have fallen ill we
simply don't know but since his death he
has nonetheless become a very infamous
figure greatly loved by his followers
and vehemently criticized and attacked
by his enemies and later critics his
thoughts and teachings can be said to be
rather syncretic as I mentioned earlier
he was highly educated and he seems to
have had an impressive intellectual
capacity and thus in his writings he
showcases a great mastery of both
philosophy and the mysticism and tries
to apply both of them but two things
needs to be pointed out here firstly
while he is highly philosophical it is a
bit uncertain if he can be firmly placed
within the fence of a tradition he held
very highly some philosophers like Plato
and the Muslim Al Farabi
but was highly critical of others like
even the rushed and even Abin Sina both
of whom he thought was misguided he used
and applied the Aristotelian tradition
in his thinking especially in these
Sicilian questions but he was also
critical of this kind of philosophy as
it conflicted with his ideas of absolute
unity instead even Sabine appears to
have been formulating a new kind of
illuminated philosophy that he sometimes
referred to as the hikmat Alma shrieked
the eastern wisdom which may perhaps be
referring to people like Sora Wadi and
his philosophy in this mystical
philosophical project he seems to be
especially fond of Hermes who is often
equated with the Prophet ADIS in Islam
indeed in the introduction to his most
important work the Buddha arif he
praises Hermes as the greatest of sages
quote I petitioned to God to propagate
through me the wisdom that Hermes
Trismegistus revealed in the earlier
ages the spiritual reality the prophetic
guidance has made
official the happiness that is sought
out by every person of guidance the
light by which every fully actualized
intellectual wishes to be illuminated
the knowledge that will no longer be
broadcast or disseminated from Hermes in
future ages and the secret from which
and through which and for the sake of
which the prophets were sent this Lent
some credibility to the idea expressed
earlier that Hermeticism was especially
prominent in Spain or in the record in
particular this isn't to say that
Hermeticism was something unique though
hermeticism was widely popular and used
by philosophers and other intellectuals
in the Muslim world generally but here
we see a larger emphasis on Hermes than
what is perhaps common among the Muslim
philosophers secondly we must remember
that while they've been sabha in did
attempt to create a kind of synthesis
between intellectual philosophical
knowledge and mystical experience the
two are not equal in any way mysticism
what we could call the Sufi aspect
dominates his writings and holds by far
the most weights but is complemented by
philosophy and Scott Johnson writes
quote this is demonstrated in urban
sovereigns emphasis on the priority of
mystical verification taktik of
discursive knowledge and more
expressively in his articulation of the
doctrine of absolute unity when taught
at Malacca what even Sabine emphasizes
the most is a direct transcendence of
plurality and experience of God's unity
within ourselves what he calls taffy
Alto heed this is also the root of his
criticism of Aristotelian or peripatetic
philosophy even if he does employ it
sometimes himself Aristotelian
philosophy looks at the world through
plurality when in truth there is only
absolute oneness he himself says quote
while studying the diverse branches of
science the true sufi sees them as a
whole as mere preliminaries the soul end
which he pursues his arrival at the
contemplation of the unity of the divine
essence and the negation of the world
and his own self this very convenient
brings us back to that very essential
aspect of his thoughts what he likes to
call and what other call the a doctrine
of absolute unity or what a Mook
raka he likes to use this term himself
and he also employs many other terms for
this kind of philosophy very
interestingly we have seen that name is
Sabina is often associated with even
Anna bean empanada B's doctrine is of
course as you know known as white a
Telugu Jude or the unity of being but as
I stated in the video about a banana B
he never actually uses this term himself
at all but it was generations later that
this came to be used as a technical term
and what is very fascinating is that
even Saba actually does use the term
want a Telugu jeweled the unity of being
to describe his own philosophy and he
was a contemporary of a banana be these
similarities between urban sabayon and
empanada BR many to the point that many
have said were claim that they are
actually saying the same thing but in
different ways in them in Sabah is
absolute unity there is nothing but God
he often exclaims in his writings Allah
who forgot God only or only God
everything in the world including the
individual self or illusions that are
non-existent nothingness and only God is
in reality it is characterized by an
emphasis on taking flight over all
multiplicity even the many divine names
and instead an intense fixation upon the
divine essence or a thought in itself
which is all of reality all the
intellectual Sciences only really lead
to this affirmation quotes man begins to
desire the incomparable object and he
enters into the scientific paths which
we have previously mentioned advancing
and meditating as he will he becomes
aware that everything is but an
attribute he then acquires the
conviction that the attribute of
multiplicity is contained within the
essence of unity and that this is the
absolute truth to which he must ascend
before which the world has no reality he
progresses from there to the reflection
of the object of his desire in the world
but no longer finding there the unity
for which he surges he abandons
everything in the world and the
reflection of God in the world
recognizing the nothingness of
everything that he has acquired through
preliminary sciences he under
stand the very voice of reality even
when they've been Sabine speaks in
philosophical terms dividing the world
into objects or different realities or
gradations of existence this is all
really conceptual and isn't real in the
ultimate sense in truth there is only
one 'no solute oneness there can be no
distinction between things at all
everything is one so far this may seem
pretty similar to the school of a banana
bee and his doctrines and it very much
is
but even Sabine and his followers were a
bit more radical at least in their
expressions of these ideas while urban
Arabi saw the world as a relatively real
and as being the reflections of God's
infinite attributes and having all their
being from God even Sabah Ian viewed the
world in everything in it as an illusion
he didn't hold the idea that we are to
know God through his reflections in the
world but that we are to pass over the
names until we see only God in his true
essence Michelle showed kovitch explains
the difference between these two in very
I think understandable terms even if I
think he overestimates the difference
between the two world little bit quote
despite occasional use of similar
formulas sometimes exactly the same
formulas the differences between urban
Arabic and urban Sabah in our
fundamental a metaphysic whose center is
a divine solipsism has no circumference
for eben Arabi
God is the being of everything that is
free been sovereign God is everything
that is the god of a banana B is the
lamp of the heavens and the earth that
urban sovereign is a son without race
whose incandescence is in itself its own
and too many these were very radical
ideas and indeed they are radical in a
sense that the unity or oneness that it
expresses is a radical unity or a
radical oneness he did synthesize
mysticism and philosophy but once God's
essence or the oneness of reality is
realized there is no longer any room for
speculation or discursive science quote
I was first led to say I have never seen
a thing without seeing God
find it then to say which is closer to
the truth I have never seen a thing
without seeing God with it then finally
to say I have never seen a thing without
seeing God before it now I can only say
hee-hee-hee
while these ideas of his were very
controversial and he was attacked by
many scholars we shouldn't forget that
he was also very much loved and admired
by many others as well the Muslim world
at this time or in any time was not some
homogenous entity were open 7 was an
anomaly there were many others similar
movements and teachers and many who
considered his ideas to be perfectly
acceptable even if they probably weren't
in a majority for example we should
remember that the Sharif of Mecca
himself was a close friend that live in
saline and may even have been his
devoted student and that according to
Vincent Cornell quote when he eventually
moved to Mecca pilgrims from the Islamic
West sought him out like no one else the
very bad reputation that have been
sabayon has had and it still has can be
much be attributed to his enemies
painting him in a very bad lights
descriptions and opinions that have to
some degree still survived to this day
and this includes calling him things
like a pantheist or heretic or hermetic
philosopher who disregarded the Islamic
law even though he clearly states in his
writings that one state's the importance
of following the Sunnah of the Prophet
Muhammad and the Quran and so on the
claim that he committed suicide has also
become sort of semi accepted knowledge
even though it most likely isn't true
there was even a fictional novel written
about him called a Muslim suicide by Ben
Salim image which I hear is very good by
the way the Sabine iya was run by his
students our study in Egypt and by a man
called eben hood in Damascus and
survived through their lines some of
them may have been assimilated into the
school a banana bee which grew to be a
lot more influential and very much
eclipsed the influence of eben Sabine
who is relatively forgotten today
nonetheless even Sabine is remembered as
one of the foremost representatives of
and ricean Sufism or mysticism and
philosophy even if he isn't as well
remembered as his contemporary even
Arabic as I've said in the beginning we
know
little about him and his school and the
same can be said about the recode Valley
and the Sufism that was practiced in
Islamic Spain at the time in general I
think there's a really interesting stuff
that can be discovered here if we dive
deeper into it who were these people of
the wadi Ducote how did they influence
even sabayon and can even saba and i
banana be said to be baptized in the
same intellectual waters there were the
currents in the region at the time and
to what degree was Hermeticism
influential on this movement I think
further research into this subject could
give us a lot in terms of our
understanding of Sufism or the history
of the Islamic world in general even
Saba an may have been a very strange
figure his philosophical mysticism
expresses realities and experiences that
are very profound and striking and often
without compromise but at the same time
and as he recognizes himself he is
ultimately trying to explain things or
experiences which cannot be expiated in
words as they are completely beyond
human conception therefore the following
words by Evan sabayon become especially
haunting and telling quote he who says I
mocks himself by comparison he was as he
lies only he who keeps silent is saved
I'll see you next time before I go I
would like to extend a special thank you
to everyone who has chosen to become a
patron for this channel I am of course
eternally thankful for your support and
this pledge will be very helpful for my
continual work on these videos if anyone
else is interested in supporting me
monetarily I will leave a link to my
patreon page in the description and I
hope to see you in a future video
[Music]